did the prime minister mislead the queen
he says the suspension of parliament was
to allow preparations for a queen's
speech
but was it as gina miller argues
designed to prevent
parliamentary scrutiny of his brexit
strategy
pick your heroes and villains in this
but the supreme court must decide purely
based on law
in scotland the court of session agreed
with the case against the government
but a week earlier the high court of
england and wales claimed it was not for
the courts to intervene
so bring on the lawyers for the
executive
to use a prerogative power
to seek to evade control
by parliament stands the
basic principles of constitutional law
on their head lord panic representing
gina miller then submitted what he
called
additional evidence a sky news interview
with boris johnson
by the journalist sam coates
he argues this interview demonstrates
the prime minister's motivation for
suspending parliament
i'm afraid that the more our friends and
partners
think at the back of their minds that
brexit could be
stopped that the uk could be kept in
by parliament the less likely they are
to give us the deal that we need
lord keen qc representing the uk
government argued that boris johnson is
not the first prime minister in history
to ask the queen to prorogue parliament
for political purposes
but assured the eleven leading judges of
the supreme court
that the pm would abide by their
decision given a clear undertaking
that the prime minister will respond by
all necessary
means to any declaration that the
original prorogation
was affected by any unlawful advice that
he might have given
you'd be helpful to have the undertaking
or given in writing so absolutely
i'd intend for that to be done well this
short section of pavement outside the
supreme court really does represent the
division
in our society right now because behind
this fence you've got protesters
who see this for roguing of parliament
as a power grab by the prime minister
an attempt to snuffle democracy then
over here you have leave supporters
who see the mps as the villains of this
beast and that the court case here today
is really an attempt to undermine what
they voted for
in the eu referendum i'm a conservative
party member
but i support raj
because i've lost trust guys over there
just think this is a cynical ploy to try
and stop
brexit what do you think about that i
don't think it is
this in itself is just a desperate
attempt
to save democracy so that they can then
decide whether they want brexit or not
and in what form
as they consider reams of evidence the
justices insist
that whatever they're ruling they're not
passing judgment on brexit this is
purely a legal
constitutional decision when it comes
out
some might see it differently jason
farrell sky news